bien loin dans les hauteurs de mende
capoue la famille diony a planté trois
hectares de cacao une variété de très
grande qualité multipliaient à partir de
plans très ancien qui existait sur la
propriété 600 pieds ont donc été plantés
ici en 2014
mais il faut entretenir la plantation
pendant cinq ans avant d'atteindre le
plein rendement de 3 des montants
octroyés comme ça y'a pas dans tron et
bio la pénurie mondiale de cacao promet
un bon revenu aux producteurs 25 euros
le kg de fèves grands crus fermenté et
sécher d'ici là la famille se
débrouillent sans aucun soutien bio pas
encore le label bio parce que ça prend
quand même trois ans dont 3 a
effectivement peut-être nous savons bio
des aides
oui y en a mais malheureusement il faut
avoir le label ou prétendre à ces êtres
bio dans l'immédiat la plantation
accessible par deux kilomètres de
mauvais chemin
on aurait bien besoin d' aide pour le
consolider à quelques pas d'ici sont
exploités 45 hectares de bananes bio
ici l'on désherbe à l'aide d'un petit
tracteur et à la débroussailleuse
et l'on se passe totalement des
herbicides pesticides ou engrais
chimiques
le label bio permettent un prix de vente
de 900 euros la tonne au lieu de 400
euros
heureusement car l'agriculteur n'a pas
touché un centime de subvention pour sa
conversion toute l'agriculture
européenne à des aides alors c'est pas
normal qu'à aujourd'hui le bio
aujourd'hui qui est en martinique
n on n'a pas des aides il nous fallait
avoir une opé bien organisé pour que
chaque culture puisse vendre sans bon
sens de sa production à une coopérative
qui elle va vendre dans les marchés
existants mais au moins bon qu'avant un
justificatif pour que l'état puisse
payer puisse donner aujourd'hui on n'a
pas l'effectif puisque on apprend
coopérative
la plantation la ronge rien portant mise
au point un produit révolutionnaire à
base de fumier de ces porcherie de
mélasse et du musc recueillies en forêt
après un long processus de fermentation
dans ses cuves le liquide sert d'engrais
naturels qui rend à la fois les plans
plus résistants à la cercosporiose et
aux parasites
c'est quelque chose d'exemplaire d'abord
et puis qui encourage peut-être aller
dans cette voie une voie du bio qui est
pas toujours non plus facile au jour
d'aujourd'hui et je pense que que ce
soit en matière de cacao ou de bananes
les process qui sont engagés mérite
toute l'attention
les leviers sont là il existe à la fois
dans le cadre du programme leader par
exemple qui donne une possibilité à des
agriculteurs de des trains promotion des
trains valorisation le feader qui par
rapport à par exemple à l'exploitation
de cacao pour la pour le désenclavement
et permettre que les routes soient
faites la promotion la commercialisation
même la transformation des agriculteurs
font leur travail aux pouvoirs publics
de trouver les dispositifs dead qui
peuvent soutenir leur développement